foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been nine years since the last
armored Core game by from software and a
lot has changed since then this
franchise skipped an entire console
generation during which time from
software doubled down on the souls-like
formula and hit higher Heights with
games like Eldon ring then I think any
of us could ever have predicted but now
armored Core is back with the fires of
Rubicon coming to all platforms sometime
in 2023 it's actually been in
development for so long that it's even
coming to last gen consoles and while I
know some of you are nostalgic for
armored Core and are super excited to
see it return I think most of us were
probably watching TGA and asking what
even is armored Core what is happening
in this trailer what's the gameplay like
and will this armored Core be any
different to previous entries in the
franchise and last but not least we were
asking will it be seoul's life
can answer a lot of these questions we
don't just have the cinematic trailer
and previous games to work off of at
this point we also now have a steam page
we have the official website a press
release and some very credible leaks so
let's dive into it so first what is
armored Core well technically this is an
armored Core it's a Mech an armored unit
for the human core inside which makes
use of so-called muscle Tracer
technology that allows for the humans
integrated control of the machine in
past games you usually take on the role
of a mercenary you are a raven pilot
open to any mission that is sent your
way fighting on behalf of Corporations
and governments and rebel groups that
are all fighting for control of this
topian post-apocalyptic world and its
resources so how different then is the
story of the new armored Corps to all of
these past games well let's use the
story descriptions on the official steam
page to help break down this trailer it
all starts with a red light a spark that
suddenly alights sort of like a nervous
system with characteristic red lightning
and energy that goes on to appear in the
apocalyptic scenes to follow what looks
like an entire solar system has just
been enveloped in Flames which then
leads to a shot of the Ashen aftermath
with the words feed the fire and let the
last Cinders burn so what are we seeing
here well according to the official
steam page for the game a mysterious new
substance was discovered on the remote
Planet Rubicon 3. as an energy source
this substance was expected to
dramatically Advance Humanity's
technological and Communications
capability
instead this substance caused a
catastrophe that engulfed the planet and
the surrounding stars in flames and
storms forming a burning star system and
then almost half a century later the
same substance resurfaces on Rubicon 3 a
planet now contaminated and sealed off
by the catastrophe extraterrestrial
corporations and resistance groups now
fight over control of the substance the
player infiltrates Rubicon as an
independent mercenary and finds
themselves in a struggle over the
substance with the corporations and
other factions so here we're seeing what
is clearly a return to this contaminated
Ashen sealed off Planet returning to a
post-apocalyptic world is definitely
nothing new for Souls fans we see a Mac
pick up what looks like a mechanized arm
or a weapon from the Ashen wreckage
presumably they're adding it to the pile
of loot or suppliers on their back and
then explosions on a distant Bridge get
this mech's attention these explosions
are from this battle where one AC unit
destroys some smaller mechs before
engaging in combat with a rival of very
similar design it's kind of hard to keep
track of all this action but we see an
energy Shield a dash
some sort of EMP goes off and this huge
stake driver is plunged into the chest
of one Mech and then withdrawn at the
end of their fight a variety of other
mechs then show there's machine gun fire
and helicopters and the main character
Mech then becomes aware of all of this
and they Dash they equip a machine gun
equip a shoulder missile kit they change
visor and dash off screen it's just
awesome it's gritty and it's metal and
it's very armored Core I also find it
interesting that many of the mechs have
the same red glint in their eyes that we
see at the start of the Cinematic which
I think might show that they're using
this mysterious new energy source but
we'll talk about that energy source a
bit later
so now that you're familiar with the
story of armored Core you know new and
old let's talk gameplay the steam page
for this game states that players will
assemble and pilot their own Mech with
3D maneuverability to freely move
through three-dimensional fast-paced
missions take on difficult challenges
and overwhelm your enemies with Dynamic
movements that make full use of ranged
and melee combat but to really
understand what this means we have to go
back and look at gameplay from past
games what you're seeing here is early
gameplay from armored Core for answer
for PS3 the gameplay in these games
often begins with Mission briefings that
let you know what you're about to do and
how to do it and why for example in this
early mission I have to be strapped onto
a Vanguard overt boost unit which lets
me rocket through the enemy's Invasion
units before then turning around and
trying to destroy the survivors once I'm
grounded on my Mac the true armored Core
combat begins combat is
three-dimensional it's fast paced and it
requires a lot of multitasking and
Resource Management I have a jet pack if
I want to fly I have a speed boost if I
need to escape I have two weapons active
at the same time that I can fire
simultaneously right now I'm holding a
chain gun and a melee blade but I can
also swap each weapon for a secondary
weapon if the situation demands it I
need to dodge stay locked on scan the
environment manage my resources my
ammunition my movement which guns I
should be firing this game has a really
high skill ceiling and I am nowhere near
hitting it I am so bad at this game but
I can see the appeal there are even PVP
modes in recent games that some fans
speak very highly of and I'll leave some
good links in the description if you
want to learn more about the series
because I really don't know that much at
this point anyway it's very Mission
based and I think the new game will be
as well there are even bonus objectives
in a lot of these missions and at the
end you get a score and a reward and
currency that you can use to customize
your machine and prepare for your next
missions there's an insane depth to the
customization in these games and yeah
that's the gist of it and you can only
really experience this now if you have
an older gen console because a lot of
these games do not emulate very well I
don't think my Mech is supposed to look
like that
so finally will this game be Souls like
well there's good evidence to suggest
that it will be so my first piece of
evidence is this official press release
that I was lucky enough to receive from
Bandai Namco there's a line here that I
haven't really seen talked about
anywhere else here it calls armored Core
6 revived and reimagined but now
introducing groundbreaking gameplay
found in the developers recent action
games
from software's recent action games or
All Souls likes I don't think they're
talking about derasane here now just how
Souls like armored Core will be remains
to be seen but from software have really
doubled down on the souls like formula
in the last nine years since armored
Core 5 and I imagine they're very keen
to bring Souls fans into the armored
Core Universe it would Breathe new life
and popularity into this Niche series
fans want something familiar to ease
them into playing the new series and I
see a lot of people arguing that this
won't be a reboot of the armored Core
franchise because it's got the number
six at the end right so it's just a
continuation but from what I understand
armored Core has been soft rebooted so
many times throughout its cross-gen life
cycle so that number six might not mean
much keeping a number at the end of this
potentially souls-like reboot might just
be in keeping with tradition at this
point but what I really want to talk
about is how much all of this really
lines up with the armored Core leaks
that were posted on reset era earlier
this year so according to user red
licorice they received a customer survey
about a new AC game with screenshots
descriptions and two 30 second videos of
gameplay and looking back at these leaks
they're pretty much a hundred percent
credible now as a lot of what this
leaker said has since been corroborated
by the new steam page
and therefore now whatever else the
leaker said is now also very reliable
and they said that the game does indeed
have souls-like elements from the videos
that they saw now previous armored Core
is clearly very removed from Soul style
combat and I have no idea how the team
is going to tweak things but listen to
how this leaker describes the boss fight
gameplay that they saw they say the boss
fight seemed very souls in terms of
speed and style the player started afar
locking on firing guns then closed in
and attacked melee and the speed and
movement all seemed very familiar in a
soul style if I had to guess I'd say
this boss was like an asylum or Taurus
demon style early boss the boss had a
life bar on screen at the top of the
screen if I recall correctly very simple
but it was more red LED styled
futuristic as you might expect angular
edges on the life bars rather than
straight rectangles
so with the press release and these
leaks I'm now very keen to see gameplay
and very curious how they'll tune the
combat to be more in line with their
recent action games I'm also very
curious to see how long-term fans are
responding to all of this I'm admittedly
very new to this series so if you're an
old fan please do sound off in the
comments we all want to hear from you
most of all I think are you excited to
return to this world are you wary that
it might stray too far from the series
Roots the zomb have like poison swamps
that we should know about anyway
regardless of how Souls like it is or
isn't the game has been in development
since at least 2017 and according to the
new steam page its development from
Miyazaki as director has since been
passed on to Masaru yamamura who was the
lead game designer of sekiro so while I
can't really imagine what the combat is
going to be like I'm confident that it's
in good hands at the very least
sounds like Miyazaki handled development
and direction of the game when it was in
its early concept stages and then passed
its direction on to be handled by
someone else or another team and last
but not least I want to explain why I'm
kind of excited for the story so from
what I've read armored core's stories
tend to hit a lot of the same notes
every time the world has experienced
some sort of disaster and corporations
and governments and Rebels are all
fighting for control no matter how many
times the series is rebooted there's
always these same story notes that seem
to be explored during mission briefings
usually honestly these stories seem kind
of dry to me but there's one new element
to this armored chord that intrigues me
so the steam page mentioned that
mysterious new substance but the leaks
that I talked about are actually using a
different older name for the substance
presumably back from when the game name
was earlier in development they call
this substance melange now melange could
be a reference to a French word which
means mix as this mysterious new
substance is a mix naturally but I think
The Inspirations of the word melange go
deeper
so there's this book and recently again
a movie called Dune that I know many of
you are aware of and like armored Core
it's a piece of Science Fiction and its
entire story revolves around a substance
called the spice melange which is
commonly referred to just as the spice
this spice is essentially the rarest and
most prized commodity in the known
universe to the point where to quote the
book it was said that it was so valuable
that one Briefcase full of spice would
be enough to purchase an entire planet
so armored Core the earlier version of
it anyway was calling this substance
melange just like in Dune and in June
it's a really fascinating substance it
has a variety of uses but mostly it's
used as a drug that with regular
exposure can significantly increase life
expectancy but also it broadens the
human mind and the senses to the point
where some humans are even able to see
deeper into the past present and future
and it's this foresight that makes some
people omniscient and it has basically
been a substance that has enabled
Humanity to master Interstellar travel
across the universe so maybe armored
cause substance is deeper than just
being this destructive force the steam
page does say that it enhances
communication after all it's clearly got
a little bit more going on with it and
to me it sounds like the familiar
building blocks of a Soul's games's
story melange sounds a bit like the
Elden ring it could be like the Dark
Soul it could be like pale blood it's
basically this thing that was
established in a distant past that we
don't quite understand and yet it drives
the entire story in this powerful and
intriguing way and also our character is
a mercenary this time we are on the
lowest rung of the ladder again you know
not unlike the undead or the good hunter
or the tarnished we have no real
affiliation and just the world open with
factions to fight for or against it all
sounds very from software and yes I'm
biased because my entire livelihood
relies on from software at this point
but damn I'm excited so go and read Dune
watch the new movie they're both
Classics And subscribe to get more news
on almond core when it drops thank you
for watching and I'll see you next time
thank you